Transcriptor: Ingea Marti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
El hombre no llegó a la Luna.
La Tierra es plana.
Darwin no tenía razón;
descendemos de los reptiles
En el año 2016, la Universidad de Oxford
ya suena como un chamuyo
esto que estoy diciendo, lo sé,
empezó a hablar por primera vez
de la posverdad
La Real Academia Española.
define este neologismo
como aquella información basada
en hechos no objetivos que apelan
a nuestras emociones,
a nuestras creencias,
a nuestros deseos.
Mi nombre es Jau,
perdón, mi nombre es Javier Fabris
honrando a mis padres presentes
pero soy Jau, el mago
algo así como un mentiroso profesional
lo que me he vuelto.
Un... o sea me dedico al sutil arte
del engaño.
Ahí está.
Como artista entendí que el asombro,
es lo principal en mi arte
porque a partir de allí podemos
desarrollar el arte.
Porque justamente el asombro,
nos vuelve vulnerables,
nos hace tierra fértil
a que cualquier
mentira, que ande dando vueltas,
penetre en nuestro ser.
Posverdades, fake news,
codiciosas campañas electorales,
publicidades, etc..
Es cierto que también
los magos sabemos
muy bien que las mecánicas del engaño
funcionan en aquellos vacíos
que deja nuestro cerebro
y que nuestro cerebro mismo,
nosotros mismos, rellenamos.
Cada vez que anticipamos,
cada vez que asumimos,
cada vez que prejuzgamos.
Pareciera que estoy defiendo la intuición,
de hecho lo estoy haciendo,
pero la intuición es algo muy poderoso,
que nos hace humanos, en primer lugar,
pero también es algo que nos puede
jugar en contra.
Se lo voy a ejemplificar.
Supongamos por un instante que
yo propongo hacer un efecto de magia
donde un mazo de cartas,
se ordena automáticamente mediante
solamente un clic.
Mazo de cartas.
Se ordena del as al rey,
cartas rojas, cartas negras.
Muy sencillo.
Tengo dos como artista:
puedo ir a lo obvio,
mostrarles un mazo desordenado,
un mazo ordenado,
la gente se asombra.
Es un camino un poco más largo,
por las cositas que tenemos
que hacer en el medio.
Pero a veces,
los artistas de ilusión,
y también los mentirosos,
utilizamos lo que llamamos
implantar una idea,
generar un concepto
que hace que nosotros
mismos nos engañemos
y que el artista no haga casi nada.
Se lo voy a ejemplificar.
Si yo tuviese que hacer esto, diría
con convicción,
mazo de cartas mezclado, en mis manos.
Es una mentira que está
este mazo de cartas
mezclado.
De hecho ahora se lo voy a mostrar
está perfectamente
ordenado de antemano.
Pero dicho entre dos verdades,
la verdad cubre la mentira,
y la mentira, pasa.
Verdad, mentira, verdad.
De esa forma nos engañan todo el tiempo,
y es un mecanismo que utilizamos
los artistas para hacer un montón de cosas
El mazo está perfectamente ordenado
no sé si se llega a ver bien.
Sin embargo,
los seres humanos tenemos
otra gran desvirtud,
que es la capacidad que tenemos
para asombrarnos con las curiosidades.
Somos curiosos.
Nos detenemos casi siempre
a pensar en ese caso,
en uno en un millón ¿no?
Tomate un vasito de vino
que vas a vivir más tiempo, y allí vamos,
todas las noches a emborracharnos, ¿si?
Por cierto la comunidad artística
me va a odiar a partir de este momento,
los magos digo.
Creemos más en artistas,
en la gente que aparece en la tele,
que a veces en grandes expertos.
Pero eso sí,
si tenemos un tema jorobado de salud,
vamos directamente a ver la eminencia
que mayor cantidad de casos de éxito
comprobado pueda tener.
Los magos no solo somos los artífices
de muchas de estas formas de engañar
pero tampoco somos los únicos.
Allí se esconde gente, estafadores,
gente que tiene algún beneficio
a partir de manipular nuestra voluntad.
Pero a mí, las posverdades en sí
me llaman más la atención todavía,
porque hay algunas que parecieran
no tener un beneficiario final.
Han tomado sustento
se han creado asociaciones de
gente que cree determinadas cosas
y a partir de ahí las defiende.
Hagamos una pequeña, un pequeño ejercicio
a ver si sale.
Con convicción, sin pensar en el qué dirán
levante la mano si hay
alguna persona que crea
que la tierra es plana.
Uno.
Bien,
después nos decís tu nombre, por favor.
Levante ahora la mano
las personas que crean
que el hombre no llegó a la Luna
y que fue todo un "fake",
una especie de programa de televisión
que pasaron en el 69.
Algunos más levantaron la mano,
ya con un poquito más de convicción, ¿no?
Lo cierto es que, el hombre
si llegó a la Luna o no,
si la Tierra es plana o no,
son cuestiones que determinan
lo que sabemos versus lo que creemos.
Y los seres humanos
muchas veces elegimos
los argentinos, es más,
lo hacemos más a menudo,
elegimos creer que sabemos,
versus saber.
A ver con qué se sienten más cómodos,
"yo solo sé que no creo nada" o
"yo solo creo que no sé nada"
para que se lo pregunten Uds.
Pareciera estar librándose una especie
de batalla, entre la posverdad,
que son estos disparates,
y la proverdad, que es
se han denominado
los dueños de la verdad verdadera
que desmiente con evidencia, la verdad.
No tuvieron mejor idea
que ponerle un nombre
a esto, lo que le saca
un poco de credibilidad
en lo que a mi me parece.
"Posverdad", en serio, "proverdad",
parece como una cosa, ahí, medio ridícula.
Lo cierto es que el decimosegundo hombre
en pisar la Luna, y el último en hacerlo,
después de seis misiones exitosas
de la serie Apollo,
el comandante del Apollo 17,
digo todo esto para los que
levantaron la mano hace un ratito.
Eugene Cernan, decía
que la verdad no necesita ser defendida.
Francamente, cuando empecé
a pensar en el cierre de la charla,
traté de buscar recetas,
para que no sean víctimas
de las posverdades.
Había muchas,
algunas más comprobables que otras.
Pero como mago,
tengo la autoridad para decirles,
que cuando escuchen una verdad,
lean una noticia,
y les parezca por extremo asombrosa,
por lo menos permítanse dudarlo,
antes de retuitear.
Lo cierto es que no todo el asombro,
es la puerta del engaño.
Cuando vean un mago, por ejemplo
cuando me vuelvan a ver
en alguna ocasión,
ahí sí, relanjense, ¿no?
déjense llevar.
Porque como les digo, no todo el asombro
es la puerta al engaño.
O sí...
A lo mejor dije algunas cuestiones
para que crean que
un mazo de cartas mezclado
en mis manos
ahora finalmente, esté
completamente mezclado de verdad.
O a lo mejor dije esto,
para mostrarles,
que ni siquiera había cartas
en primer lugar.
Lo cierto es que solo con el corazón
se puede creer.
Y lo esencial, es increíble a los ojos.
Muchas gracias.